[Musique]
qui a l'air payée pour les billets pas
mieux
c'est une influenceuse pas mal ouais alors qu'est
-ce que tu fais je vends de la merde
le succès d'une croisière de luxe ça dépend surtout que
tu
profites du moment c'est toujours
oui monsieur oui madame non
ce que
tout le monde  égal
thomas quand vous êtes capable de porter un toast au
dîner du capitaine
à l'amour
je ne suis pas fan de la gastronomie
[Musique]
le navire passe sous un
capitaliste russe
et un communiste américain sur un
luxe de 250 millions de dollars
reste concentré
[Musique]
nous  il faut créer un bon groupe
[Applaudissements]
qui suis-je
tu es le responsable des toilettes
non
ici
capitaine